as you know we are currently
crowdfunding a beautiful storybook
written by myself and illustrated by
Heather ponton called Snow White and the
Widow Queen it really is a desire to
recapture storytelling to dive back into
the old stories and I thought that as
we're thinking about fairy tales it
might be a good idea to put out some old
Patron only videos that I've done over
the years which interpret fairy tales
it'll give you a good idea of what those
videos look like what it means to
subscribe to the symbolic world but
it'll also be you know a good time to
celebrate these fairy tales we'll start
with Sleeping Beauty and look at why she
Pricks herself on a spindle but then we
will move on to Snow White Jack and the
Beanstalk and maybe a few more so if you
haven't yet please back Snow White and
the Widow Queen and in the meantime
enjoy
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
so as many of you know I am working on
some fairy tales working in part now
right now I'm working on a version of
Sleeping Beauty and
I've been thinking a lot about Sleeping
Beauty I guess for years and there's one
thing that I really kind of bother me I
guess it was the question of the spindle
like why does she prick her finger on a
spindle and so I looked into it and I
tried to figure out why that would be so
I thought that maybe bringing you uh
through my process of figuring out what
I think at least the spindle seems to
manifest
uh could be helpful and I mean helpful
if you're in interested in the question
of Sleeping Beauty but also helpful in
order to see the process that I usually
go through uh to figure out what these
things are about and so
the first thing that I looked at was
whether or not there are other
traditions and so this is important a
way to do that in the Bible is to often
look at uh what you would call midrash
or Legends or things that surround the
biblical text
in order to notice if there are
differences if some details are
different sometimes even in scripture so
for example if you look at uh stories in
um
in the book of Samuel and then you look
at stories in the book of Kings for
example and you can try to see what the
same what's different and sometimes
seeing that something is preserved or
something has changed can actually help
you understand what is going on and so
when I looked at the the Traditions
there were two Traditions it seems and
one was that
Snow White uh Snow White Sleeping Beauty
printer finger on a spindle for those
who don't know what a spindle is a
spindle on a is either on a spinning
wheel or sometimes it can be a hand
spindle and so what it does is that you
take flax or usually it was flax at the
time but you could probably have it with
wool as well you would take flax and
then you would pass the you would you
would um
attach the the flat I don't know how
they started it they would like attach
the flats to the spindle and then as the
wheel turned the spindle would spin like
this and it would spin the flax together
and then with your hand you would kind
of just let it go and it would rotate
around the spindle and then it would
create a bundle around the spindle so
that's why the spindle has a kind of
vertical shape you know it's a it's a
rod but sometimes it's a little pointy
because you want the thread to neatly
let's say uh get gathered around the
spindle and so now the problem with that
let's start with the spindle the problem
with that is that spindles aren't pointy
like they're not pointy in a way that
you can break your finger on and so
that's something that people you know
the same kind of person that uh the same
kind of 14 year old atheist but for
fairy tales would be like oh it's
ridiculous you know spindles aren't
pointy this is a silly story yeah this
is nonsense or whatever but usually when
something doesn't make sense in the
story at least especially a story that's
lasted a very long time
uh it's actually not a it's actually not
a how can I say this it's not a sign
that the story doesn't make sense it's a
sign that the story makes so much sense
that the people who are remembering it
are willing to accept a disjunct between
the meaning of the story and actual
manifestation in the world and so if you
look at uh even the idea say maximus and
uh you know origin and all these early
church fathers they talked about how in
the text in the biblical text what they
called the idea of ambiguous that
problems of ambiguous ambiguous problems
in the text like when there's
contradiction even between the different
uh tellings of the text or when there's
something which is very obscure and very
strange uh often it's actually a sign
that there's a lot of meaning there
because why would you tolerate
kind of why would you tolerate for a
very long time to preserve a story that
is that is just complete gibberish or
meaningless it doesn't mean that that's
the case all the time I mean obviously
sometimes there can be gibberish and
meaninglessness and stories but the idea
is that you don't necessarily just
discount it especially if it's an
important part of the story like the
spindle in the in the uh in the Sleeping
Beauty story so that's one so the other
tradition was that she pricked her
finger on a strand of flax so now it's
not the the spindle where the flax gets
transformed and turned around and coiled
around this this axis but now it's
actually the thing like the the wild uh
early part of the process where it's
just like a piece of straw basically a
piece of flax and then she she pricks
her finger on that and so
interestingly enough it seems like those
are actually opposite from each other uh
when you start to kind of understand
what's going on they seem like they're
opposite from each other but the fact of
them being opposite from each other
um
this is another thing about symbolism is
that sometimes that can help you
understand the meaning because
opposites are bound by a category that's
why they're opposites and so you you see
that sometimes in when people also mock
stories they'll say well it's not what
you said it's the opposite of that well
if it's the opposite it's still Bound by
a higher category or else you wouldn't
recognize it as an opposite right the
opposite of high is low the opposite of
orange is in a bowling ball right it's
like if it's an orange and if it's an
orange and this finds something even
weirder it's like an orange and a duck
and those two things like orange and
duck how do they fit together you can't
you struggle to understand why one would
be switched for another but if but if
it's like the spindle that gathers the
thread around it and then the flax which
hasn't been gathered yet and hasn't been
brought together then you're like
interesting you know this is at least
seems to be in the same category so so
that is something to pay attention to
when you're interpreting the the text
and so the next thing to do is to not
interpret the idea of what the spindle
is apart from the story and not
interpret elements that you're trying to
understand apart from the story you
always have to try to stay inside the
story as long as possible
and so
you have to look at the at the event
what are the events so there's an evil
fairy that is not invited to the
chrismation of the the the Queen the the
King's Daughter
and
because she's not invited she gets
annoyed and uh and then when the other
fairies they give her a blessing and
those blessings are usually virtues you
know it should be beautiful she'll be
good she'll be truthful she'll be
graceful it's all these Goods that they
are giving to Snow White as their
blessing and then the last fairy that
wasn't invited to the party will come up
and so obviously she's going to prefer
her curse now
what's interesting now about the curse
is that the curse doesn't actually
follow at least in appearance doesn't
follow
the other blessings they're not it
doesn't see it seems to be to not fit so
the fairies will say she'll be graceful
as this she'll be beautiful as that you
know whatever she'll dance she'll be a
great dancer I don't know like giving
her qualities and then the the uh the
evil fairy says this is going to happen
to her and she will die so she'll prick
her finger on a spindle or she'll prick
her finger on a piece of flax
and and she will die so
like why is it why does that go together
so this is where I've been meditating
for quite a while and trying to figure
out what was going on and so the idea
then you know this is kind of like what
my brother talked about Jordan Peterson
the idea is like well let's understand
what a spindle is what it does what it
looks like and so take some time to
watching YouTube videos about people
spinning flax it's like what's going on
you don't even understand because
they're not trying to explain to you
what you want to understand and also
because of these spinning wheels have
changed quite a bit as you look at the
spinning wheels like there's no even
there isn't even what seems to be the
spindle on it where is it like what's
going on in the Disney version
interestingly enough they don't even she
doesn't even break her finger on the the
spindle she pricks her finger on
something called the disc staff which is
not the place where the thread gets
wound up but it's actually this like
this big Rod that people put on spinning
wheels to to tie the flax before it's
processes so they'll tie this Flack
before it's processed so it's kind of
holding somewhere and then they'll pull
it into the process and so that it gets
spun around the spinning wheel so it
seems like the people who made the the
Disney movie uh didn't take the time to
understand what his spinning wheel is
but I understand their intuition because
they ended up making the
the spindle which is in the spindle they
they joined it with like the most
vertical kind of phallic masculine thing
that was on the on the spinning wheel
which ultimately that if you haven't
guessed yet that's definitely part of
what the symbolism even of the spindle
is
um so what's going on in the what's
going on in the story so there are
several things that are kind of brought
together the first thing to notice
this is where this is where it really
started well this the easiest one to
notice is the is the idea of
looking at other fairy tales and
noticing the idea of someone falling
asleep around the time that they're
teenagers and that when they fall asleep
it has to do with uh with beauty it has
to do with
um
at least in this case it has to do with
blood uh in the case of Snow White
there's also before before she eats the
Apple there's also a pricking with blood
that where she falls and so it's like
you know what's going on and it does
seem to have to do and then she's of
course woken up by a kiss and so this is
something I mentioned before I think in
in some of these videos it never doesn't
necessarily has to do with puberty and
with the transformation of the body at
the at that time that a woman becomes a
teenager and that the
the effusion of blood can either be the
the menstrual cycle itself and that
would have something to do with the
wheel or it can also be the loss of
virginity which would have something to
do with the disc staffer with the the
vertical part and so those two effusions
of blood which can happen you know after
a woman enters into the into
um
into adulthood seems to be what is
referenced here or what is played around
you could say in terms of imagery so you
can imagine that you could read it in
two ways you can read it as a young
woman who enters into the menstrual
cycle and then she kind of loses you
could say she doesn't
she loses herself in the sense that
she's caught in this cycle and she
doesn't and it's like she doesn't know
what it's for and that's also has to do
with like this weird curiosity about the
the about the spinning wheel like she
doesn't no one's told her what this the
spinning wheel is for right we've kept
it away from her all this time and so
it's like she gets there and it's a
surprise she starts her cycle and it's
like what the hell is this like why what
is this Blood like what is going on and
so you can imagine that it's you know it
says it throws her into a loop and she
doesn't know what the reason for that is
and that is something like a kind of
dying and you see that of course if you
compare the Sleeping Beauty to Jairus
daughter which I've done here
you can see how all of this is connected
right you know Jairus daughter dies at
her puberty has to do with the fusion of
blood of the woman that Christ heals on
the way there so it's all kind of
connected together
um but then there's also the idea of the
the actual prick of the of the spindle
which would have something also to do
let's say with uh the idea of a young
woman who who let's say loses her
virginity without totally understanding
what is going on and what the
consequences of that are and then she
kind of she dies to the let's say to the
world she dies in the sense that she
doesn't she she doesn't have love you
could say it that way and so she
there's a there's a relationship with
her body with sexuality with everything
that hasn't to do with the the with with
love which would be the purpose or the
joining the joining with the male in the
proper way through marriage and through
you know uh that would bring her into
the into uh Womanhood so it's all these
things that are kind of being suggested
now
again so why the piece of flax or the
spinning when or the spindle though so
why is it that in particular especially
considering that the spindle isn't sharp
uh you could kind of prick your finger
on a piece of flax that maybe makes a
you know like on a straw that kind of
makes a little bit more sense
uh
and I think it has to do with what
happens to the fairy so think about it
this way
the spindle is what gathers the string
around it so the spindle is a vector of
unity and so it makes sense and so it
also makes sense in terms of the
masculine aspect of the spindle that you
know it's the the origin of the name the
origin of the seed the origin of the the
identity of the family and so
the the uh the witch is not invited to
the party and so because of that
she basically tells uh Sleeping Beauty
or tell the king that his daughter is
going to prick herself
on this unity and so you can imagine it
exactly that way that is that the
problem of excluding and including and
the problem also of unity is that unity
in its positive sense is the vector
around which that that you can gather
things but unity in its negative sense
can be something like a sword something
like a prick that can that can hurt and
that can appears you could say uh and so
it's as if she's saying she will live
with the negative consequences of
masculinity with the negative
consequences of unity uh because you've
excluded me from the kingdom and so it's
the excluded one who then kind of calls
back to the unity and and uses it as a
curse so that is definitely I think the
way to see it now if you see it the
other way then it also makes sense it
makes sense uh in in the opposite way
which this is can also help you
understand how symbolism also works is
that
she's she's excluded
and she doesn't fit
and so she's saying you are going to be
prick your finger not on the final
process but on the raw wild straw before
it's United and so it's like I am this
this wild straw I am this piece of straw
which was not brought into the string
which was not bound and wound around the
spindle and that is what she's going to
prick her finger on and so then it also
then it's more related to the idea of
the menstrual cycle and the the
remainder and the residue which is which
is bound up in this story now of course
it's important to understand that
this is why symbolisms have been so
powerful is that
none of the elements of the story
actually directly mean the analogies
that I pointed to so it it so it's not
that the that the spindle represents
a phallus or something silly like that
right like that that the kind of modern
interpreters would love to say it's that
there are analogies between the imagery
and the meanings and those analogies
point to something even higher which
would be something like the relationship
between unity and multiplicity the way
in which things are gathered into one
the way in the way things Fray apart the
way in which things uh you know and the
relationship between fraying apart
falling falling uh sleeping dying uh and
then being awakened by by Love by
attention by care from above so there's
all these images but it's like you can
still if you see the analogies can help
you and so you know it so the idea is
that now as I'm writing the the Sleeping
Beauty story I can just slowly pull in
images and threads and uh things that
will point you or will help you have
more in insight into what why it is that
it's something like a spinning wheel and
a uh and a spindle because like I said
at the outset when you look at the story
it might seem arbitrary to us although
it's it's clearly not because you know
stories that are preserved and
remembered and cared for for a long time
you have to you have to remember too
that
a good a good way to understand this is
that like the Grimm Brothers or Perot or
the people who gathered the
um the fairy tales you know in the 17th
with the 17th 18th century they they
only gathered certain ones like they
probably heard a lot of versions of all
these fairy tales like maybe hundreds of
versions but they gathered them in a
certain way there are certain ones that
they brought out and they kind of or
they they compress together in order to
show them to you but at the same in
Grimm's Fairy Tales there are a lot of
fairy tales that you've never heard of
that have been forgotten that no one
cares about but somehow some of these
fairy tales are kind of person persevere
and become touchstones for culture it
becomes like the main let's say uh fairy
tale stories that we know and if there's
an element in those that seems strange
to us and we don't totally understand we
should be careful not to discount it but
rather pay attention and try to see well
if it's so illogical and random and and
arbitrary then I don't think it would
have been remembered this way I don't
think people would care for it and you
know would celebrate it in the way that
they did and so uh so yeah so I hope
this is helpful to kind of
you know I help you see what my process
is and how it is that I meditate uh on
these things sometimes I meditate on
these images for years I just drop them
in the drop them in the intuition box I
don't know what to say and just leave
them there and as I move along sometimes
they'll resurface and I'll have a bit
more insight they go back down they come
back up uh until and then sometimes
there's pressure like let's say I'm
writing the story then there's like a
pressure where I really want to
understand this so I kind of keep it on
the tip of my tongue or right on the tip
of my mind all the time even as I'm
cooking or if I'm doing other things and
then it's it's ruminating is the word
material likes to use and then all of a
sudden it clicks and I like oh yeah
that's what it is so so yeah so I hope
this was useful everybody and thanks for
your support and I'll talk to you very
soon bye-bye